l'inauguration du grand prix de monaco
dans un nouvel éclat aux courses de
grand prix
[Musique]
peut-être 10 millions d'euros dans ce
camion faut faire très attention
on a une belle première course sans
incident on a des jolies grid girls
alors là tout est bien aulas c'est un
peu la panique tout au milieu le camion
il peut pas tourner même avec l'iphone
mêmes règles a eu peur c'est la panique
vous plaît juliet des balles dans 10 à
est une des rares femmes pilotes
britanniques d'origine argentine
elle vient accueillir sa très chère
bugatti parti d'angleterre quelques
jours plus tôt c'est un peu la voix
cassée
marché
cagnottes des candidats
deux voitures avez-vous et on peut vous
aider comment on peut sortir la bugatti
en premier mais la bugatti n'est pas en
avant non elle est là à l'arrière un
décor elle est juste là dans tous les
cas il faut que j'avance un côté
assiette ce que si tout va bien
c'est très bien c'est juste au milieu
maintenant vous pouvez la descendre
c'est une grande responsabilité
oui ces voitures sont très précieuses
beaucoup de valeur peut-être 10 millions
d'euros dans ce camion faut faire très
attention
ce sont deux vieilles dames oui les deux
vieilles dames
il faut prendre la bugatti de julia est
une voiture mythique au volant de sa 35b
de 1929
sept pilotes de 65 ans n'a besoin de
personne ou presque
voyez les larmes les femmes et vingt
sept jours indépendant mais à la fin ils
sont besoin
[Rires]
14 avril 1929 premier grand prix
automobile de l'histoire de monaco
ce jour là de nombreuses bulles getty se
trouve sur la ligne de départ
l'inauguration du grand prix de monaco
d'un nouvelle éclate au cours de grands
prix c'est un défi idéal pour les
bugatti et l'une d'elles peint en vert
fourbi par le britannique williams mène
pendant un bon moment mais elle est
attaquée dépassé pendant un certain
temps dans une grosse mercedes blanche
voiture difficile a conduit sur ce
circuit est piloté par pierre à thiolat
le britannique william se remporte
l'épreuve à une vitesse moyenne de 80
km/heure succès retentissant dans toute
l'europe
la légende est en marche
après des études d'avocat julia épouse
d'ingénieurs italien championne de tir
pilotes d'hélicoptères et d'avions à ses
heures a fini par se lancer aussi dans
la course automobile
mais là n'est qu'après 20 17
je suis venu ont été voir les grappes
historique et
un internat santal et les parfums d
huile de ricin avec les méthodes et
et la chanson des motos ça m'arrive
quelque chose je met à voler mais alors
vous vous grattez pour courir voilà ça
s'est passé
je ne sais pas
à quelques mètres de là alain pas lent
car le directeur de course rend visible
commissaires techniques chargés de
contrôler chaque voiture
alors voilà devant une très belle
voiture italienne avec un moteur italien
l'écurie italienne est un pilote italien
c'est bon elle est conforme tout est bon
bien sûr vous venez d'où de quelle
région de florence
alors pas de perdre
ah oui oui des perles aura l'année
belles voitures monde des belles
voitures c
on est comme des petits enfants des
petits garçons la très belle mais qui
est très rare
et puis on verra ce qu'elle va faire
surtout pendant les courses maintenant
le cas pour gagner amateur passionné
originaire de nice pierre profite de
l'événement pour approcher les voitures
qui le font rêver
vous voyez à monaco à l'époque ouais si
ce n'est pas une machine
damon franc 26 les relier le numéro de
l'époque fait vraiment configuration de
l'époque on retrouve numéro 26 à
l'époque elle avait couru magnifique
j'avoue qu'on ne peut pas rester
insensible devant une oeuvre d'art
pareil c'est
je dirais tout l'ensemble parce qu'il ya
déjà le côté technique la construction
de cette voiture une structure tubulaire
si on regarde bien ce siège vous voyez
la position du pilote et des plus
inconfortables tenir sur des grands prix
avec un siège au cired
il ya rien n'y a pas d'épaisseur de boue
ce n'est pas une voiture de tourisme
c'est le sport pur pas une minute à
perdre avec mario son mécanicien
juliette est sa deuxième voiture de
course une maserati de 1951
je suis trop haute
cette partie qu'on avance un policier
là dessus c'est ça j'ai peur que si je
le dirige vers moi il se casse on peut
peut-être
la personne à quelqu'un qui aime ce
genre de voiture une belle femme la
belle a signé une belle voiture
c'est un vrai plus dans le monde de
l'automobile on mobilise le lendemain
matin la voiture de julia passe au
contrôle technique indispensable pour
valider sa participation
venez faire le contrôle est ce parce que
j'ai deux formes une heure
[Musique]
du moteur au système de freinage
aucun détail n'échappe aux commissaires
et il y a un petit problème il faut
absolument placer des bouchons sur les
réservoirs au cas où la voiture se
renverserait pendant la course
ce qui exaspère julia non mais j'attends
non mais je trouve que celui du coup le
savait parce que il y à il ya les jeunes
qui évoluent comme des fous voulaient
dire fond les accidents
moi j'ai là mais la voiture s'est
incliné moi je sais que c'est sûr parce
que c'est moi qu'elle a connue elle à
chaque fois nous avons le même problème
non c'est la première fois l'année
dernière j'avais son âge n'avait pas de
pression dans le réservoir et mettez ça
c'est ce qu'il nous faut la sécurité
c'est probablement le plus important
plan et veut pas que les pilotes se
blesse nous essayons de respecter au
mieux les règles de sécurité
ces sommes tous là pour nous amuser mais
la sécurité reste une chose importante
côté sécurité ou ne plaisante pas à
monaco
quelques heures avant les premiers
essais petit rappel du règlement pour
les pilotes
c'est un peu d'effervescence en est un
c'est le départ de l'épreuve les
premiers contacts dix ans avec les
autres montre heureux ici on va leur
donner les dernières consignes après ça
va ça va être parti voilà c'est le début
encore bonjour nous avons une vidéo d'un
tour de circuit
ça vous donnera une petite idée de ce
qui vous attend ce week-end
[Musique]
quoi
on n'est pas là uniquement pour gagner
on est là pour s'amuser
or le plus de plaisir c'est vrai qu'il
faut un gagnant
mais je peux vous certifier ici à monaco
le directeur de course et ses assistants
ne tolérerons aucun comportement
antisportif
au paddock les mécaniciens s'activent
pour être sûr que ces vieux bolides
capricieux prendront bien le départ
[Musique]
julia elle se prépare à sa première
séance des 6
[Musique]
tout lien entre comme en ce moment je me
sens mieux comme je sais deux ans
une amie riche héritière allemande est
venue la soutenir
je suis impressionné moi aussi je cours
vous venez ici j'ai très peur elle est
très courageuse
je suis vraiment impressionné
on
[Musique]
les voitures d'avant-guerre s'élance sur
ce circuit mythique couronne
habituellement les moteurs de formule 1
[Musique]
les virages serrés et la piste étroite
rendent la conduite exigeante et des
dépassements difficiles
[Musique]
en bord de piste mario scrutent chaque
passage de la bugatti
[Musique]
alors elle réalise en boutons premier
tour où elle fait un bon temps jusqu'à
présent le faisait chauffer le moteur
[Musique]
la direction de course coeur névralgique
du grand prix historique visite
exceptionnelle dans ce lieu très fermé
ici on peut à tout moment arrêter la
course est attribué des pénalités aux
pilotes changé
celle de potes j'arrive pas à le joindre
pour l'instant à la
mais pour l'instant on a une
intervention dont on croit pas le faire
tout de suite on verra ce que ça va
donner
fidrych fiction général pas du tout
c'est une course à part entière avec
tous les mêmes problèmes que l'on peut
rencontrer pour le grand prix de formule
1 et je dirais même des problèmes
supplémentaires parce qu'on a beaucoup
de voitures en piste et on n'a pas
forcément que des programmes des projets
pilotes professionnels ce sont des
propriétaires de véhicules qui groove
dans ces voitures qui ont une licence et
qui n'ont pas pour autant la qualité
peut-être pour être sur un circuit donc
des fois ça vous pose quelques problèmes
peu de course de vieilles voitures sans
accrochage poster tout le long du
circuit commissaire spécialisé médecins
et sapeurs pompiers se tiennent prêts à
intervenir
[Musique]
après la première séance d'essai le mari
de julia et ses amis prennent la voiture
en charge
infatigable la pilote britannique repart
cette fois au volant de sa maserati
à
alors pour la wii
on
vous êtes contente
oui mais ça m'a impressionné naissance
du secteur des médias et dont le bouchon
descola
là vous repartez ou directeur c'est
formidable
impeccable dans la conduite
[Musique]
ce jour là julie a terminé les
qualifications très loin derrière le
premier pilote mais peu importe les
voitures de collection ne possède aucun
équipement de sécurité et les courses
historiques sont dangereuses
pas question pour elle de prendre le
moindre risque
je ne regarde pas l'état je suis content
des deux sorties beignets
elle aimerait que la mafia oui mais
temps je les connais pas en cumulé
j'ai pas important non pour moi non
naturellement je veux pas être
naturellement je vais pas faire
c'est la première fois que l'ensemble
dans une voiture
l'un des mal classés les blancs
cette fatigue et non pas terrible
plus convivial
au volant on a beau la vie
le soir tombe sur la principauté
fatigué par les essais de cette journée
les pilotes se couche tôt la course de
demain va demander beaucoup de
concentration et d'énergie
[Musique]
à monaco le public n'aime pas vraiment
se lever aux aurores
si les gradins sont encore déserté un
attroupement se forme du côté des stands
on se bouscule pour voir les stars
au premier rang
pierre asnières son idole alain prost
mettant son rythme
trois ans
stark oui tout à fait ça c'est le
rappelle vraiment des souvenirs un
garçon très agréable un français
curico pour oublier la shoah
selon la fed les grandes courses qu'il a
gagné ça fait plaisir de le revoir
aujourd'hui en chair et en os
on est ensuite avec le groupe historique
n'ont jusqu'à maintenant c'est des
voitures qui sont de collection donc on
est complètement dans l'historique la
première d'autres puissances et à 115
ans et c'était déjà il y avait déjà les
pics logiquement ça c'est les épaules en
charge les enfants
ça c'est l'événement est super
intéressant mélange
[Musique]
il ya la musique
déjà on n'a pas le temps de voir les
voitures donc par le bris on essaie de
retrouver la marque de la voiture c'est
une ferrari mais les matins donc grâce à
la sonorité on arrive en quoi à deviner
les voitures depuis de longs - julia ton
ce jour avec impatience
à ses côtés sur la ligne de départ aux
autres concurrents petite parenthèse
pour les bugatti une dame est là et ça
fait plusieurs années qu'on la voit
régulièrement
donc c'est du lard de valence d'agen et
qui nous pu lui dire d'être un don vous
démarre avec une 35t me suivant nous a
dit si on ne partira pas ça se passe
bien j'ai un peu effervescents mais ça
se savait pas que du folklore c'est très
sympathique par samassa
on a une belle première course sans
incident on a des jolies grid girls on a
tout est bien
on
le fan club officiel de la pilote
britannique attend en bord de piste
[Musique]
85 ans plus tard ses pilotes revivre
comme s'il y était le premier grand prix
de monaco
je suis très très fier c'est une chose
incroyable de voir les manières pourrir
dans une course classique qui plus est à
monaco quand vous êtes ici vous entendez
toute signature le bruit terrible qu'ils
font je pense que c'est quand même le
plus impressionnant donc oui je suis
très fier
[Musique]
les courses s'enchaînent toutes les 30
minutes et dure toute la journée les
bugatti intraitable sur le circuit de la
principauté au début des années 1930 ont
bien du mal à tenir la cadence
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
comme le laissait présager des essais
julia se retrouvent en fin de classement
loin derrière son compatriote matthew
christ et son alfa romeo type ob de 1934
[Musique]
pour le podium
le protocole ressemble à celui du grand
prix de formule 1 la foule en ondes
[Musique]
de retour au paddock après sa deuxième
course
rien n'entame le moral de julia
accueilli par son fils jean baptiste
vous êtes heureux de ne pas avoir les
mêmes
messi
tous les halls offre martelant c'est ce
que je prendrai le